what is the best thing about my company
the best thing about Mike Huckabee is
that he is the most natural most gifted
communicator among all the Republicans
for running today all right I hear
people say that about him but he's not
connecting to a lot of the country do
you think that's fair to say what do we
underestimate the part of the country
that he's connecting to because he was
sort of thought of as a joke in 2008 but
then really ended up coming in second
after mit you look at the voters he's
trying to appeal to he's trying to
appeal to working-class blue-collar
conservative Christian Republican voters
what he might identify we might identify
as that as the the Sarah Palin voter the
sarah palin particularly the voter who
sort of traffic's in resentment against
the elites and he's you know and making
the assumption they're gonna play a
dispositive role in the Iowa caucuses so
that that's that's what his strategy is
and again as a communicator as someone
who can take a complex idea boil it down
and connect with people even people who
don't agree with him um you know he's
he's the best bar not so do you think
that plan can work by talking to this
group of people which by most accounts
people think is getting smaller and
smaller and that their power is waning
do you think that that route could still
work maybe it could by going through
Iowa in some of those early states he'll
get the momentum even if he's not
talking to sort of the bigger Republican
electorate that route will work if he
says the right thing you couldn't be the
best communicator but if your message is
wrong yeah or if people hear something
that you're not saying or if you're
talking about something else it's not
going to work yeah so that's the big
question for at this point